lichtteilchen also toni können gefilmt
werden 100 milliarden bilder pro sekunde
machen es möglich ein zuschauer hat mich
auf der straße auch das heutige thema
angesprochen und ich habe mir dann
gedacht das ist so spannend da mache ich
direkt mal ein video zu denn es gibt
neue erkenntnisse herzlich willkommen
für klick von pflanzen wechseln
das team von kaiser bruder von der
universität tokio ging feiern mit einer
hochgeschwindigkeitskamera über das
menschliche vorstellungsvermögen hinaus
mit der technik konnten sie dinge
sichtbar machen die das bloße
menschliche auge beim besten willen
nicht wahrnehmen kann viel der forschung
und der entwicklung der kamera das ultra
schnelle prozesse in der physik genauer
beobachten zu können durch das
japanische modell der
hochgeschwindigkeitskamera können
schwingungen von atome in kristallen die
plötzliche verdampfung von materie oder
auch die ausbreitung von wärme
untersucht werden im hintergrund auf
jetzt ein paar aufnahmen der kamera
problem an der kamera die auflösung der
bilder
die ist nämlich auf 450 x 450 pixel
beschränkt die kamera kann also kaum mit
einer kleinen handy kamera oft im
letzten jahrtausend mithalten
diese methode die bei der aufnahme
angewendet wird muss der kurze
infrarotlicht impulse eines titan saphir
leser welche durch eine raffinierte
optik in zeitabständen von gerade einmal
15 pikosekunden eine mikrosekunde ist
eine millionstel sekunde nacheinander
auf das objekt treffen die reflektierten
signale werden dann von einem sensor
aufgenommen forscher der washington
university in saint louis sind jetzt
noch einen schritt weiter gegangen
sie haben ihre eigene loveless encoding
compressed und zur farbfotografie kurze
rally cup kameras mit 100 milliarden
bildern pro sekunde dazu genutzt um
licht im speziellen einen nach tegel
aufzuzeichnen
was ist ein macht google oder auch macha
tegel ein massaker bildet sich dann wenn
sich das fortbewegen de medium schneller
als das eigentliche medium bewegt also
wenn wie im versuch der studie licht
licht einholt bildet sich ein macht
regel von
wissen wir es hat immer die gleiche
geschwindigkeit unter allen umständen
allerdings gibt es materialien die licht
brechen die licht foto nie werden kurse
an jedem atom oder molekül das sie
passieren gestoppt und fliegen dann
weiter je nach material kann dieser
stoff länger dauer diesen effekt haben
sich die forscher zunutze gemacht das
fortbewegen medium ist also ein
lichtpuls im disco nebel
er wird kaum abgebremst also gebrochen
aber es wird gestreut und das ist ja der
gewünschte effekt von nebel umhüllt ist
das ganze von einem silikon schlauch in
den dann das licht durch die nebel
gestreut wird dort bewegt sich das licht
aber durch längere stopps in silikon
langsamer so dass die quelle des lichts
schneller fliegt als das von ihr
gestreute licht es entsteht der macht
gegen die tat zu einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt hat die verteilung dieses
freilich die form eines macht die spitze
des kegels wird von freilich schweißen
gebildet die sich von der spitze des
laserpulse nach hinten ziehen so die
forscher etwas ähnliches passiert ja
auch beim überschallflugzeugen diesen
macht regel dann als überschallknall
hier fliegt das flugzeug schneller als
der schall und bildet deshalb den pegel
und so sieht die macht tegel bildung bei
nicht auf hier könnt ihr übrigens mir
ein aber oft augen drückend und mir am
besten immer noch einen auf die glocke
leben und ansonsten bestand bleibt dran